apple's airpods pro 2 are finally here
and you're probably wondering if it's
actually worth upgrading from your old
air pods whether you've got the airpods
2 3 the pros or even the originals i'm
gonna give you the answer in this video
and be sure to watch through to the end
because the answer actually changes
depending on which ones you already have
so let's get started on the surface it
seems like not that much has changed
since the design looks generally the
same but apple fixed a bunch of issues
that i personally had with the previous
airpods pro and all at the same 249
price as before but before i get into
why i personally upgraded to the airpods
pro 2 i've got to mention another huge
upgrade in my life my new e-bike from
our sponsor propella who make
lightweight and affordable pedal
assisted electric bikes complete with
compact and swappable battery packs and
an lcd display to check your speed
battery life and adjust the motor
settings and i've been using the
propeller ss at our campsite with my
family for the past month and we
absolutely love it since it makes long
rides effortless and more enjoyable
we've already put 150 miles on the
odometer and my wife can't get enough of
it so check it out using the link below
with the coupon code maxtec 50 for 50
off today now getting back to the
airpods pro 2 the physical size hasn't
changed at all compared to the original
airpods pro but there are actually quite
a few differences even on the earbuds
themselves now you might have missed
this but apple confirmed that the
placement of the acoustic vent has been
moved to the top of each bud and in its
place they've added a new skin sensor
alongside the already existing optical
sensor in a slightly different location
to make in-ear detection work more
accurately and that's actually very
important to the battery life since
there's a smaller chance the buds will
accidentally remain turned on when you
take them out which is very annoying so
i'm glad they made that change and this
year the new airpods pro 2 charging case
itself is now 11 heavier than before but
it's for good reason apple has added
multiple features to the case including
a metal lanyard loop so you can easily
attach it to things without requiring a
case but of course you'll have to buy
the lanyard accessories separately on
top of that the case now finally has its
own built-in speaker which now plays new
tones to let you know when the battery
is low or when pairing is complete which
is very convenient and not only that but
apple stuck a u1 ultra wide band chip
into the case itself so you can use the
find my app to locate its precise
location like you can with the air tags
using the new speaker to play a loud
noise to help you find it more easily
and that right there is going to be a
huge deal for a lot of people because
previously only the airpods themselves
could be pinged but if they were inside
the case you wouldn't be able to hear
them so people would lose their airpods
all the time because of that or on the
other hand some people would lose just
the case itself while still having the
earbuds which makes them basically
useless but that's finely fixed now that
the case itself has a speaker as well
but now let's get into what matters the
most and that's the actual quality of
the earbuds themselves the airpods pro 2
now come with a new low distortion audio
driver with a custom amplifier so it
should improve the sound quality
especially thanks to the new h2 chip for
sound processing and a bunch of other
advantages like helping the airpods pro
2 get two times better active noise
cancellation which i'm personally super
excited for because it was already
really good along with that the h2 helps
with giving them better battery life 6
hours for the earbuds themselves
compared to the previous 4.5 and 30
hours with the charging case compared to
24 which we can all argue is one of the
most important features in earbuds and
when your charging case is low on
battery you'll now be able to use your
magnetic apple watch charger with the
airpods pro 2 or of course mac safe
charging which is my favorite iphone
feature ever now one feature i
personally didn't expect at all was
dynamic transparency mode that uses the
h2 chip to process noise 48 000 times
per second so it dynamically and
instantly filters out loud and harsh
noises while using transparency mode
which will help you hear people much
easier when using it and another cool
new feature is personalized spatial
audio which uses ios 16
combined with your iphone selfie camera
to map out the size and shape of your
ears so it knows how to make spatial
audio sound the best and it's also
pretty cool that they've added a new
extra small ear tip size so that younger
people or those with smaller ear canals
can finally use them but on top of that
apple has finally added a feature that
i've personally been asking for ever
since the original airpods volume
controls yes you can now swipe up and
down on the stem to adjust the volume
which used to be the most annoying thing
ever because you'd have to either grab
your phone or ask siri to change the
volume which would be kind of
embarrassing to do in a public setting
and that feature right there might be
enough for some people to upgrade going
even further the airpods pro 2 now
support bluetooth 5.3 just like the
iphone 14 lineup and the apple watch
ultra with some notable improvements
like multi-stream audio which allows
both earbuds to be connected at the same
time which should help improve sound
quality especially thanks to the new lc3
audio codec that also uses less power on
top of that le audio should technically
also allow multiple pairs of airpods to
connect to one device at the same time
as well as a single pair of airpods pro
2 maintaining a connection to two source
devices at once so you won't need to
switch between your iphone and your mac
like you did before but a disappointing
realization is that the airpods pro 2
will not support lossless apple music
like we thought it would so it seems
like apple's gonna give that feature to
the second gen airpods max first when
those come out but of course the new
speaker driver should help them sound
better and we'll definitely test them
out as soon as we get them in our hands
so definitely subscribe right now and
now let's get into discussing who should
actually upgrade to the new airpods pro
2. if you've got the original airpods or
the airpods 2 i would 100 upgrade
because of the massive amount of new
features as well as the battery life
improvements that you'll likely notice
because the batteries in your current
air pods are probably already getting
very old and don't last as long and
chances are you'll be blown away by the
noise cancellation and transparency mode
features that are now even better than
before alongside the new apple watch and
mac safe charging features which are
much more convenient so definitely
upgrade now if you have the earpods 3
you've only had them for less than a
year since they launched in october of
last year so chances are they still feel
very fresh and new to you and the audio
quality is actually really impressive on
top of that you're likely already used
to the max safe charging feature and the
longer battery life which is basically
the same as the new airpods pro 2 so
there's gonna be less of a difference
but honestly the in-ear seal design of
the airpods pro are so much better
combined with noise cancellation and
transparency mode it's truly a unique
experience so if you have the extra cash
and we're thinking of upgrading now is
the time because we likely won't get new
airpods pro until 2025
but if you'll have to stretch your
budget to make it happen you'll probably
be just fine with your airpods 3 for a
bit longer and finally if you already
have the original airpods pro it's gonna
be a mixed bag in terms of who should
upgrade our sister and editor angelica
is upgrading from the original airpods
pro to the second generation because
she's currently having issues with
connection and battery life since hers
are now getting pretty old on top of
that she's really excited for the apple
watch charging feature because she has
the belkin three in one charger so it'll
be very convenient to charge them on the
apple watch puck and of course she gets
the added bonus of better sound quality
and the noise cancellation features but
on the other hand if you're currently
very happy with your airpods pro in
terms of the noise cancellation and
battery life and you're not really
experiencing any issues you might not
notice that big of a difference with the
new second gen and maybe the find my and
lanyard features on the case don't
really matter to you and in that case i
honestly wouldn't upgrade so with all
that said hopefully this video helped
you make a decision and if it did click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and check out one
of those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]
you